こんにちははじめ社長ですはい大変お登勢いたしました
今日から
新チャンネルスタートしますありがとうございますありがとうございますありがとう
ございます
[音楽]
長かった取っちゃもなかったもう何か一から作ろうと思ってたんだろう多分でも作ろう
と思ってたのはもう去年とか
去年からもうちょっと作ろうと思ってましてまあいろいろ考えてどうしたら作れるのか
なとか何をしたらいいな花とかどんな人と
どうぞ
第じゃないのかなとか色々考えながらようやくこの日を迎えることになりました
いやー
大変でしたねー
なんか今までずっともう一人で動画ちょっとに作ったりしてきた塗ったんでまあそれを
何か他の人とやるっていうのはすごい
なんか
不思議な気分というか難しかったんですけどちょっといろいろうおおおおさをして考え
ながらまだ未完成なところもありつつもようやく
チャンネルスタートすることができますはいチャンネル目は
動画の概要欄のにから飛んで下さいなんかそれらしい名前になっていると思いますが
あってなんで作ろうかと思ったというとあの
北
今いろんな人に支えられて youtube
やっております友達とか後輩とか
東京から来てくれたた夏とかほんといろんな人と一緒に動画を作っていますはい
で動画外でもそいつらとすごい仲がよくてあの
めちゃくちゃ実は動画がい動画街が今
楽しいんですよ
遊びも含めたりなんか熱情の会話とかいろんなところで面白くてそいつらというと
創立らといるところとかを
面白くてもったいないというかそれを動画にできれば一番いいかなと思って
どぉすればいいんだろうと思った時なんかそれを見せるところはこのチャンネルじゃ
ないなと思いました
もうこんちゃんねら僕がしたいことをたらたが
するチャンネルで
いいんじゃないか他の行った方のそれをどうするかって言った時に
新チャンネルを作るべきなんだなと思って新チャンネルを作るというところまで至り
ました
なのであの新チャンネルのテーマは肇社長が主役ではないというところでございます
あ
しなくちゃねそうだねほんとなんか面白い奴らに囲まれて
昔合わせなんですけどそれぞれとまた何か新しいものを作っていければいいなと思って
おりますたち
たっちゃ
どうだ新チャンネルば
チャンネルのことについて俺が言うんですそうだね
俺がもしメンバーのことはいいんでいやまたバレてねああまだはる技ですね大丈夫
新チャンネル
そうですねやっぱ一さんの
周りにいて思うんですけど
安倍さんの周りって結構面白い人が本当に多くて
なんか
この人
の面白さを見せたいなーって思うことは本当に
たた大彼らの良い部分というか
あと一さんのあの動画とってない部分
の普段の面白さというかそういう
ワイワイした
ef ん1なところせられたらなって思いますね
それでねこうなんかそれを見せると小川はじめシャツをチャンネルじゃないって言う
まあここはも僕が今まで通りしたいことを好き勝手言っていくとしてそれ以外の部分を
それ以外の僕の周りの人このいいで何が起こってるのか
日々2塀の中動画にできればいいなと思ってチャンネルを作りましたので
あの本と僕以外の人がいろいろ出てくると思うので是非僕の周りの
面白いことをみんなに共有できればいいなと思っております
本当に全然猫の食べると雰囲気が違うと思うので是非是非その子のチャンネルで味わえ
ない
雰囲気とかもと住んでいただけると作れると思います
新チャンネル願いおら下にあると思いますのでぜひ卒だから見ていただけると
ありがたいです
[音楽]
そしてチャンネル名は
go 飛んでからのお楽しみだへ出てるよ
頑張ります頑張ります音と合わせて考える
[音楽]
me
uh